everything in your life will change when
you realize that you do not want an easy
life stop praying for easy stop praying
for convenience you don't want it
because you don't want to photocopy
copy they over and over and over and
over again you want variety you want
change you want something different but
with that variety comes uncertainty
comes pain comes challenges and from
that pain comes purpose ultimately your
purpose comes from your pain and the
more pain you go through the more
challenges you take on the more you
stretch yourself in your comfort zone
the more you're going to be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well you can only help
people to the extent and you have been
through something so the next time
you're going through some pain tell
yourself this is the best because it's
your chance to show yourself and the
world What You're Made Of and will
Define the impact that you will have
rule number two give more value most
entrepreneurs don't charge enough you're
so worried about getting rejected or
losing clients because of a higher price
that you'll charge just enough so you
stay just above the survival line that's
not how winning businesses are built if
you can't break your survival mentality
you'll stay in survival mode forever so
the first brand deal that I ever got was
for five hundred dollars from a major
telecommunications company and they
wanted me to write for their website and
they hired me they hired nine other
people to write an article and they said
write 300 words we'll pay you 500 bucks
and for me 500 bucks at the time I
thought this is great it's amazing I got
my first deal 500 bucks this is Cash I'm
pumped but more important I'm getting a
link from a huge company and for anybody
back in the old school SEO days if you
get linked from a big company that can
mean a lot for your business to take off
for rankings so I would have done it for
free just for the link
so they gave me the 500 bucks but I
didn't just write the 300 words because
I wanted to give more value I wanted to
get paid based off the value that I
could provide and so I had to show them
here's how much value I can bring and so
instead of writing 300 words I wrote
1500 words right five times more than
what they asked and then I made a video
talking about it and then I also
promoted it to my newsletter list promo
to my audience let people know when that
article came up here it was and so what
happened as a result of me doing all
this work I was the only one doing it so
when they came to the end of the series
I had my posts that were crushing it and
then nine other people were doing what
was asked the 300 Words Their bare
minimum what is asked of you is the bare
minimum that's your ticket into the door
if you just did what they asked that's
not enough that's not giving them insane
value and so I was the only one that
they hired 10 of us went in I was the
only one who kept going because I
brought them way more value now I a
charging morph what I was doing it went
from 500 bucks per post to a thousand to
1500 the 2000 kept increasing my prices
because I was bringing them the value
and they could see it rule number three
raise your standards one of the hardest
things in the world to do is to raise
your standards everything that you are
surrounded by keeps you where you are
your friends your family the media you
consume your habits everything your
environment has been perfectly created
to keep you exactly where you are right
now if you want to raise your standards
you need to raise your environment I met
up with a friend of mine recently who
I've known for 12 plus years and he was
talking about how much I changed over
the years and for those of you hardcore
fans of mine you can go back to my
content and see how much I've changed
but specifically for him he's an
entrepreneur I've seen his business grow
over the years and he talked about how
much more willing I was to be
truthful to be honest to push him to
push him when it was uncomfortable and
believe in him even harder to say the
things that are uncomfortable that need
to be said that will help him get to
where he needs to be to believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves he's seen the changes in me
and how much more direct I am how much
more confident I am and how that's
helped him directly in his business and
his life where did that come from
it came from my videos
if you go back and watch my old content
I didn't have a lot of confidence I
loved what I was talking about I thought
it could help but it didn't have the
emotional commitment to the words a lot
of my messaging belief has stayed the
same but my confidence and my commitment
and my standards have raised because of
the videos that I consume because my
environment was a certain way and it was
pretty good
but now in watching my own channel
watching my own content being a
subscriber to myself making my videos
for me and then sharing it with the
world I feel like I have all these
people on my wall and More in my ear
every day I've got Steve Jobs talking to
me every day I got Oprah in free in this
year I got Elon Musk back over here I've
got all these people every day all these
successful people in my ears constantly
when you are around successful people
you will become more successful when you
hang around these people you will start
to think like they think you will adopt
their mindset you will see the world the
way that they see the world and so you
have a choice look at your current
environment look at the people who are
currently hanging out with look at the
media that you are currently consuming
does it lift you up does it build you to
be a better version of you the thing
that you want to go off and do the thing
that you need most in your life are you
surrounding yourself without enough in
your environment are you taking enough
of it in I want more belief in my life
and so I get a daily injection of belief
through my channel right I inject myself
with belief every day
so that if you come around me and you've
got a cold and you sneeze on me right
you're a negative person you're
pessimistic you sneeze on me with your
negativity I'm good
because I have so much belief in me from
the injection rule number four focus on
your distractions the thing that you
keep getting distracted by might be the
very thing that you should be should be
focusing on so many people keep asking
me hey Evan how do I stop getting
distracted how do I focus on my work if
you keep getting distracted is for one
of two reasons either one you don't like
the work that you're doing or two you're
afraid of it working out the solution
isn't to keep avoiding it the solution
is through and chances are that's saying
that you keep getting distracted by is
actually the thing that you should be
focusing on you just don't know how to
make it a business yet now I'm a big
believer and as soon as you get an idea
you test you try you Tinker you
experiment idea to action the two
percent difference let's go let's go
let's go so a quick example with my top
10 series when I first started the top
10 series I didn't think it would become
a series I didn't think it would become
this huge thing that that later Define
my channel and became the most popular
series on my YouTube channel it started
off because a friend of mine Mark posted
a Blog about Kanye West and how he
interrupted Taylor Swift and this was
multiple years after he had actually
done that and like come on man you can
learn learn from Kanye dude stop hating
on Kanye yes he gets himself into
trouble he deserves it but he's also a
genius he's also someone that you could
learn from he's won more Grammy Awards
than anybody at his age he convinced
John Stevens to change his name to John
Legend because it had an old school
voice there's all these amazing stories
about Kanye that you can learn from his
success and so I thought forget this I'm
not just going to complain I'm going to
take action and I'm going to make a top
10 rules for Success from Kanye West and
I went out myself and researched all
these different clips and I put them
together and sure there's a lot that you
can't learn from Kanye there's a lot
that you don't want to model or copy and
emulate into your life and business I
get it but there's still 10 things at
least you can apply and learn from him
to make you a better version of you and
so I just did it and I released it and
people liked it it was meant to be a
one-off video just to show my friend
Mark to say just watch this Mark watch
it learn from it you could learn from
Kanye and it was a distraction project
right I'm working on my business I'm
working on trying to create something
Mark creates his blog post and I get
distracted by it and think I want to
make a video and I put my business on
hold instead of saying I no no forget
that idea I need to stop doing that I
need to I need to just focus and forget
all distractions no I said you know I'm
gonna put this on hold because I can't
stop thinking about this so I'm going to
do this get it out of my system and then
I'm going to come back to my main
business although that little thing that
I did just as a one-off to show my
friend Mark ended up becoming the entire
Channel
you never know
and so it's idea to action that thing
that I got distracted by ended up
becoming the beginning of an entire
series an iconic series on my channel
and it might be the thing for you too
also if you want more motivation and
confident check out our 254 series the
link is in the description below the
people who win work the hardest because
they love what they do create an outline
ain't a schedule what I found really
helpful for me was to create an outline
at the start if you're doing work that
you love you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it rule number
five align your goals with your dream
this is why I think 10-year plans are
almost useless because if you are
chasing down your dreams then your goals
will change so many times over the next
10 years think back to who you were 10
years ago take today's date and imagine
yourself 10 years ago could the person
who you were 10 years ago
actually predict what a great life would
be for you right now today 10 years
later if you've had any kind of growth
over the past 10 years then it's no it's
in no way you've grown so much the
person five years ago two years ago let
alone 10 years ago has no idea of what
you're capable of and so the danger of
creating these 10-year goals for
yourself is you can hit your 10 nickels
you can have a goal and hit it in 10
years I just think that it's small
compared to what you could do because if
looking back 10 years the 10-year
younger version of you could not
actually predict what would make you
happy right now then what makes you
think that you right now can create a
great plan for you looking forward 10
years you can't and that's the best now
I don't think goals are useless I think
goals are great I think goals are
stepping stone along the path of your
dream you have to just make sure that
your goals constantly align with your
dream rule number six model success no
nobody has the exact life you want
nobody this is why so many people have a
challenge learning from mentors because
you're looking for one person to teach
you everything that one person does not
exist because you want a unique life
because the perfect you doesn't exist
out there yet you have to create it it's
on you and so the way to get through it
is to model from different people it's
to look at I want to learn this from
this person and this from that person
and this from this person this from that
person and mix all of those things
together to build an amazing life for
yourself this is partly why I created my
Channel I want to be able to model
success from all sorts of different
people and every video that I make I've
learned something from all the people
that I've profound I've learned
something from them if I personally me
Evan Carmichael haven't learned
something from that video then I don't
post it rule number seven don't set off
with the wrong thing I think too many
people settle too early on in life for
the wrong aim people settle for the
wrong business people set up for the
wrong career people settle for the wrong
relationship because they're in such a
rush to get to their aim that they end
up with a life of suffering if you don't
know your aim yet that's okay it's
normal and maybe you found it but lost
it that can happen too there may be many
times in your life where you don't know
your aim the solution is to taste is to
test is to try is to explore until you
find it because otherwise you live a
life filled with regret knowing that you
are capable of more but you settled for
Less rule number eight learn reading
should not be your priority learning
should be your priority there used to be
only a small number of ways to learn it
used to only be reading or maybe going
to lectures and learning from people but
reading was one of the fastest ways to
learn because you could take somebody's
life and in one book and that's the
whole thing all the lessons and here you
go chance to learn now though there's so
many different ways to learn there's
podcasts there's videos and so you need
to understand what is the best way that
you learn reading does not have to be in
your top priority but learning has to be
the difference between where you are
today and where you will be in five
years that growth will be in direct
relation to how much you learn how much
you feed this brain right here with
knowledge that shifts the way you think
but it doesn't have to come from reading
so looking at my story as an example I
used to read all the time growing up I
used to read I am 39 now so I used to
read a lot growing up it was the only
way to learn and the idea of being able
to look at any famous entrepreneur and
look at their story how they got started
that was a lot of knowledge that that
allows you to step into somebody's world
right if you don't like your environment
you don't like the people around you you
don't want to become your parents or the
people in your community you want
something better you want something
bigger then you need to start to
surround yourself with those people and
reading is a great way to step into
their world and so I used to read every
single week not quite every day but
almost I was reading a lot I was
voracious but as soon as video came out
I quickly shifted I would much rather
watch a video than read a book I just
learn better that way I would much
rather have an Elon Musk video and watch
him and see him tell his story and look
at the body language then I would
reading a book about somebody else
telling Elon musk's story that's me
that's how I learn I listen to zero
podcasts because auditory is the slowest
way for me to learn if it was the only
way if the only way to learn was to
listen to podcasts and I would be all
over it and I would force myself to do
it because I love learning but because
there's so many different options and I
love video first I default to learning
through video but
so videos
full day of my life number two would be
reading and a huge drop down to number
two I'll read maybe three to four books
a year and then number three would be
auditory which would be podcasts and I
consume zero podcasts I don't know that
I've listened to an entire podcast all
the way through it would have to be some
person that I can't find the video or a
book on and the only information the
only way to get it is to listen to a
podcast rule number nine use your pain
your story is the secret to finding your
purpose the thing that you feel is
holding you back and that you're afraid
of is actually the thing that you need
to lean into so that you can help other
people your purpose in life comes from
your pain and you can either succumb to
that pain and let it control you for
life or you can use that pain to change
the world so my biggest pain was being
an entrepreneur and struggling and
suffering and making 300 a month and
only 30 percent of a company and turning
down extremely high paying jobs to go
off and be an entrepreneur and live the
entrepreneur life and I was too
embarrassed and ashamed to tell my
friends that I was struggling and
suffering and not making any money
and I hated myself and I felt like a
loser I felt like I was adding no value
I felt like I was getting up every day
and working and working and working the
entire day and not seeing my friends and
not doing any other stuff that I wanted
to do because I was so focused on
building my business and I wasn't
getting results like nothing was
happening
every single day
and I was tired of living way below the
poverty line and I told my business
partner that I quit and that was the
worst day of my life that one day when I
decided that I quit
eventually I woke up the next day and I
said I can't quit I'd rather no one
failed than not know and I'd ask myself
who else had done this before who else
had built a software company how can I
learn from that person model their
success to build my own company up
but I love helping entrepreneurs now
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that was my pain
[Music]
should you have a
have it or not depends on your
personality for some people the only way
they act is if they are all in if they
don't have a plan B if they burn the
boats but for others the best way to get
them to take action is actually small
starts to taste to try to test if you
want to quit smoking do you go cold
turkey and just quit or can you use
Nicorette and slowly wean yourself off
both strategies can work but it depends
on your personality the same thing
applies in business I had a guy call
into my morning show today on Instagram
and he's in a bind he is making a lot of
money he's making three hundred thousand
dollars as a base salary pulling in over
a million with commissions at his
current job but he doesn't want to do
his job anymore he's tired of doing his
job he wants to have a bigger impact he
wants to make more money yes but he
wants to do something that's fulfilling
you know he wants to do something that
is coming from his soul and he's worried
that starting over starting from scratch
he's gonna lose all this money from this
high paying salary and he's not going to
be able to find success
great
he's an all-in kind of guy
the challenge with all in kind of people
is you can't just do things on the side
the smart safe logical practical way to
do it would be keep your job and in the
evenings and on the weekends start your
business get it going when your side
hustle is making enough to support
yourself you can quit your job and go
all in on that business but you have
something to fall back on you've got
your business it's growing right you're
making some money if you can support
yourself part-time from your business
than if you can go full time you'll make
even more money that's what makes sense
it's practical it's logical
but if you can't do it if you can't stay
consistent because you're an all-in kind
of person that plan won't work for you
the way to get through it is you have to
go all in
take a leave of absence go all in give
yourself a year and recognize that it's
not fatal whatever job you're at if this
is your problem whatever job you're at
you have a skill set
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen in the next year
well maybe you don't make it
like maybe your business is zero right
you make zero money from your business
you have to go back and get another job
at least you know
it's better to fail and to know than not
to know
you have a skill set you can go back
again another job maybe you don't burn
the bridge with your company and you can
get that same job back if you want or
maybe you move on and get an even better
job
it's not fatal you're not screwed for
life and if you don't do it you will
always regret it
and so he's wrapping up some of his
deals and then he's going to take a
leave of absence and go all in his
business to find out
to know because this opportunity that he
has in his head has a limited time frame
and if he doesn't do it he's going to
regret it and hate himself for the rest
of his life rule number 11 Chase your
dream chasing down your dream even if
everyone around you thinks you're crazy
is the only way you're gonna win I like
to say that everybody has Michael Jordan
level Talent at something everyone yes
you you right there you you could be the
greatest of all time at something the
problem is most of us settle for
something just over survival something
just good enough to get by instead of
going for something that you could be
the greatest of all time at the toughest
choice I ever had to make in my life was
whether I should become an entrepreneur
or go take this six-figure job travel
around the world in Investment Banking
and I thought I wanted to be an
investment banker but I had this thing
clawing gnawing at me saying I need to
at least try this entrepreneurship path
just a test just to see nobody in my
family was an entrepreneur I didn't have
an upbringing of Entrepreneurship I
didn't have heroes or Role Models around
me who are entrepreneurs and I wanted to
model and be like them I thought I
wanted to be a banker but when this
opportunity came up I did not want to
live with regret that's the final filter
through which I made my decision
when you're faced with a really tough
decision you have to make your big
decisions with your heart and the small
ones with the head
what do I do the the most difficult
decision in my life what do I do do I
take this job or do I try to be an
entrepreneur make 300 a month and have
30 of a company what's that what's the
best call
[Music]
with regret
I asked myself if I'm 100 years old and
I'm sitting in a rocking chair and I'm
in a retirement home and and I'm I'm
about to go this is it this is the end
of my life when I look back on this
moment right now I look back on it what
will I regret more
saying no to the job or saying no to the
business
I thought you know what I can always get
another job I could I mean it be the
same job it may not be in Asia like this
one was
may not be traveling as much if I can
get another job that's similar this
business I don't know if I'm ever going
to get the shot again I don't know if I
don't know if this will ever come around
again
I'm gonna regret it if I don't know
and I adopted the mentality that I would
rather know and fail than not know I had
to know rule number 12 Play smart I hate
spending money until I'm making money I
think this is how so many people end up
going broke you take all the money you
have pour it into your business and
because you don't know what you're doing
yet you fail I end up losing everything
taking that one shot May mean you're in
debt for the rest of your life I want
you to take a smarter path so I look at
my YouTube channel as an example I've
started this Channel 10 years ago it's
crazy just over 10 years ago what a
crazy ride but when I started it I had
nothing and I didn't want to spend my
money on hiring a bunch of people and
investing into gear and equipment and
everything else and so I started by just
asking a friend of mine Mark who's been
a long time friend of the channel if he
would come and film me he had a video
production company at the time I said
Mark can you come and film me for one
episode and he did and he came in and he
filmed me and it was a lot of work and a
lot of editing afterwards but he did it
because he was a buddy of mine but he
wouldn't do every video like that and so
I had to find other ways I had to borrow
equipment from my friends and when I
couldn't borrow their camera anymore I
used the I want I want to pull for my
cell phone but this didn't exist 10
years ago I didn't I didn't have this
capability 10 years ago I used whatever
phone I had whatever camera I had these
tiny little things I don't know if you
remember the flip Cam that I would just
prop up on on a desk in front of me on a
bookcase and it would tilt and so the
video itself would be a little bit
looking like it was moving because it
wasn't it wasn't fully stable sitting
there on the Shelf I had sold my
business I had made some money I had
another successful business my website I
had eight people on my team but I don't
want to spend the money until I'm making
money I
healthy practice maybe I'm a little too
uh risk averse maybe I care too much
about protecting my Capital I don't know
there are some people who go in and they
they take out a huge loan invest
everything they have and and sometimes
they hit
sometimes you hit that's that's the
appeal that's the attraction sometimes
it's gonna hit but most of the time it's
not really ruin the 13 stick with your
goal most people don't hit their big
goals because they don't believe that
they can because you've trained yourself
that when you set a goal and when it
gets hard you quit if you're on a diet
and that food comes in and it smells oh
so good you eat it you're training
yourself that you set goals and don't
follow through you set goals and you
don't follow through you set an alarm to
wake up at a certain time and you hit
the snooze button first thing in the
morning you set a goal and you did not
follow through and so now when you set
new goals you've trained yourself you've
conditioned yourself that I'm the kind
of person who doesn't follow through so
instead of do it anyway I'd switch it to
do it because I said I would sticking
with your goals doing it when it's hard
that's how you build self-respect
self-esteem and self-confidence rule
number 14 do difficult things you don't
want an easy life you don't want to sit
on the beach and just be served drinks
all day long that might sound appealing
right now if you hate your life but it's
not what you actually want you want to
do difficult things your self-confidence
self-respect self-esteem comes from
doing difficult things you want to be on
a hero you want to be on a journey you
want to make an impact all of the Heroes
that you look up to right now look at
where they came from look at the journey
they went on they suffered a lot of pain
to get there you want to follow a
similar road so don't hate the pain
recognize it for what it is your chance
to show yourself in the world What
You're Made Of so I recently came back
from doing my tour 22 cities 90 days and
I broke my neck along the way and thank
you everybody for the warm wishes and
having you guys in my back pocket
sending me all the love every day was
was super helpful and appreciate you and
so many people saw me doing what I was
doing with this giant Netflix on with
this huge you know cut and Scar across
my forehead is it this side yeah this is
still a little bit of a scar right there
they saw that and said man you're so
inspiring I see you in the hospital
still doing a live stream and I am
telling myself some BS excuse as to why
I can't get up and go to work and and
that's amazing and that's uplifting but
the real reason why I did it why I kept
going wasn't to try to be an inspiration
to everybody watching it was to be an
inspiration to myself
it was to show myself what I could do is
that I'm in pain every day at the
beginning they had this crazy concussion
but then once that subsided I still had
I still had pain I'm still in pain that
this is months later and I'm still in
pain I'm still recovering I'm still
going through rehab just that hurts like
so much it's crazy I'm still in pain but
I want to make myself proud I want to be
an inspiration to myself because when
you do difficult things and you get
through it that's how you build
self-love not by taking it easy and only
doing the things that are within your
comfort zone if you're in your comfort
zone all day long you hate your life it
means that you're setting tiny goals for
yourself that you know you're going to
accomplish and you're basically just
photocopying your life every day is the
same is the same is the same and it's
all inside your comfort zone that's not
why humans are built to do you want to
grow you're a hero you want to go on a
journey you want to do amazing things
you want to help others rule number 15
hate mediocrity to make a real change
you have to hate your life good is the
enemy of great if you're good you're
good it would be nice to have more but
you're not willing to do the crazy scary
painful things that require to get great
because you're good you need to realize
if only for a few moments that you hate
your life you hate it you're capable of
more way more this is nowhere near this
is nowhere near maxing out this is
nowhere near the max of your
capabilities you should hate that you
need to hate that and then you make a
powerful decision to change so if you've
ever been to a Tony Robbins Unleash the
Power Within event the three and a half
day event his most powerful exercises
that he does is his Dickens exercise and
what he has you do is write down your
limiting beliefs he has you write down
what are the things that that you do
that is holding you back the belief
system you have that is holding you back
the things that you know you need to act
on that you're not doing why is it that
you're not doing it and what is it
holding you back from accomplishing and
that's a great thought exercise but
unless it's emotional you're not going
to take action right you know it fixing
that would be nice it'd be good it'd be
nice right yes but you still like your
life it's the problem you don't hate
your life you're not desperate enough to
make that happen you think well do it
tomorrow I'll do it next week I'll do it
next year no you need to hate your life
right now or that thing will never
happen and so what Tony has you do is
you take those three limiting beliefs
and then you project forward and it
takes you down I think five years and
ten years and 20 years into the future
so now you imagine you're live five
years into the future that thing that
you're afraid to do that thing that you
have on your head that limiting belief
of yours you haven't fixed it yet what's
the result what happens what do you look
like in five years that you still
haven't done the thing what happens to
you in five years and then in 10 years
and then in 20 years it takes you deeper
into the pain basically each time that
your life is terrible right you never
fix this thing you never chase that
opportunity you never go after the thing
you know you're capable of and he puts
so much pain on you through this
exercise it lasts I don't know maybe 20
minutes he put so much pain on you
but then it forces you to want to make
the change right now and then he'll snap
you back the idea isn't let's stay
negative forever right as entrepreneurs
we don't we don't want to do that I
don't want to be negative forever it's
using negativity and negative forces in
a really acute sense in these little
pockets these little moments to force
you forward to force you into action
because when you hate something you're
gonna change it
when you've hated something in your life
it's an immediate change I need to make
that change immediately but again when
you're good you're good you don't do
anything about it
and so whatever it is that you want in a
life
you have to be desperate to go and Chase
it down you have to
and the only way to do that is to hate
your current situation rule number 16
surround yourself with success raising
your game starts with raising your
standards raising your standards starts
with raising your environment and
raising your environment starts with a
decision to make it so I just finished
my three-day Workshop here in Toronto
where I teach people how to become
thought leaders and transform them so
they can take the ideas that they have
here in their head and blow it out to
the world start building a business
making money having an impact and I was
super fortunate to have two people there
at the workshop who I've known for a
decade plus friends of mine who I've
known for a long time typically is
people who fly in from around the world
but I was really grateful to have these
two people here and it was a really
interesting conversation that came out
of it from both of them and then that
led to my wife and other people who I've
known said over the last two years Evan
you've really turned it up a notch you
you seem to have accessed a different
level and and I want to know how I can
access that too I know I felt it too
I mean it's great hearing it from these
people who know me but but I know I felt
it too and maybe you guys have felt it
too if you watch back my videos that are
two three five years old
seen a shift
I'm still talking about believe a lot of
the message is exactly the same but the
confidence the standards the
expectations have gone up in the videos
I've gotten better I care more now how
did that happen
I'm not some magical unicorn creature
you can do it too it happened because I
chose to continue to surround myself
with Excellence with the videos I make
my videos for me
the top tens that Mentor means this year
I can make it for me because I want to
be around Excellence every day and
here's what happens when you're around
people who are pushing the limits and
doing amazing things every day
slowly it seeps into you it doesn't
happen on a daily basis but it's a
cumulative effect where if you're around
Steve Jobs and AP giannini and one of my
parents and Howard Schultz and Kanye
West if you're around them every day if
they're talking in your ear every day if
you're watching the top 10 cementaries
every day you're around it slowly it's
going to seep into you the more you're
around success the more that success
mindset will seep into you it just will
and what that does is change your
perspective
and gives you more confidence and gives
you more courage
and that made me step up that maybe go
and do things that otherwise I would
have been scared to do that made me go
and do this crazy tour of 90 days 23
cities when I broke my neck and then
kept going on the tour all of these
things that seemed impossible to me at
the time that then I said I'm gonna do
it
the thing that gave me the strength and
courage to do it
is all of the content that I've been
consuming it's the people I've
surrounded myself with who've had
success that make me want to be more
successful myself rule number 17 Break
Free where you start from does not have
to be where you end up you didn't choose
your parents your community your
neighborhood you didn't choose that
being born but at some point you become
an adult and then it does become a
choice to stay exactly where you are or
break free all of your Heroes all the
people you look up to all the people you
respect and want to be like they started
with less than what you already have
right now they started from a worse
upbringing from fewer opportunities of
what you currently have available to you
right now so you have to decide
do you want to win big like they did do
you want to escape do you want to break
free do you want to come back and be an
inspiration and lift the world around
you up
or do you want to blame complain about
where you started and stay there forever
rule number 18 don't fear rejection
rejection leads to success all you have
to do is look at the people that you
look up to look at the people that I
profiled on my YouTube channels and what
you'll find is rejection after rejection
after rejection so rejection leads to
success you know this intellectually you
already know this but when you get into
the situation where you have to face
rejection then your emotions take over
your fears take over and you don't do
the thing that you might get rejected
for even though you know logically
because in that moment your emotions
your fear are greater than your logic I
had a life-changing fear of rejection
situation happened to me in Paris when I
was 18 years old and I was there when I
was on a street outside the Notre Dame
Cathedral and I had a map in front of me
and this cute girl comes up to me she
asks you for directions
and I wanted to ask her out and I was
too afraid I was too embarrassed I was
too ashamed I was too worried that I
might get rejected in my head the only
thing I could think of was I want to ask
her out and she might reject me she
might say no and so what did I do
nothing
now if I had logically stood to the side
press time out you know pause the
situation say Evan logically what makes
sense logically you know she might say
no
and you're okay you'll move on with the
rest of your day logically she might say
yes why is why is she coming up to you
asking for directions why is she asking
for directions when she already speaks
perfect French and she seems like a
local right
logically that's what makes the most
sense logically I should have summoned
the courage to go off and do it but in
the moment
your emotions take over your fear takes
over that idea that you might
end so what did I do nothing I let her
walk away
and ever since that day
I reminded myself that I would rather
know and fail than not know and I use
that painful moment to whenever I am
thinking about doing something I'm
afraid of rejection for or afraid of it
not working out then I have to do it
that that moment is what led me to
become an entrepreneur because a year
later when I had the chance to have my
dream job and make 100K a year travel
around the world or be an entrepreneur
on 30 of a business and make 300 a month
at that picture in my head
where I was thinking I can't let this
happen again I don't want to live with
regret I would rather no one fail than
not know rule number 19 have a cause
having a cause will make you feel like a
superhero it'll allow you to do things
you never thought you'd do and give you
the courage you never thought you'd have
all of your Heroes had a cause and if
you want to stop selling sugar water and
change the world it's time to find yours
I love the Steve Jobs story I'm a huge
fan of Steve I have his poster on my
wall as one of the five people that I
look up to on a daily basis but one of
the things that I really find most
valuable about having a cause is it can
allow you to have the courage to be the
Evangelical person even if it's not
naturally who you are I look at Steve
Jobs and I see someone who is naturally
talented who is a great salesperson who
has the Gift of Gab who loves being in
the spotlight who is that person who
likes being up front and center and so
it's easy to go off and be that person
now you combine that with a cause and
you get a company like apple but having
a cause can make you you Evangelical
even if you are introvert and shy and
don't like the spotlight I know because
I'm talking about myself
I am an introvert I don't like talking
to people I don't talk to the person
next to me on the airplane being in
front of the camera makes me nervous
being in front of a giant audience makes
me Shy I'd much rather be at the back of
a room than be the center of attention
one of the things I used to fight the
most with my agent about was he would
say that Evan you don't want to be
famous that's a problem like yeah I
don't want to be famous it's not about
me it's about the cause and recently it
started to sink in that by me becoming
more famous I could spread the message
more but it's one of the biggest things
that we kept fighting over because I
don't crave the Limelight where a lot of
people they absolutely have to have it
but when you have a car that forces you
to the front I make videos because I
want to help entrepreneurs I make videos
because I struggled so much your purpose
comes to your pain I struggled so much
and started my business I want to make
the path a little bit easier for the
next generation of people coming through
I'm making videos and content and
speeches for the 19 year old version of
myself that needed to hear this stuff
and so I feel it's my responsibility is
my obligation I have to do it and it
forces me out into stages that normally
I would say you're crazy I'm on this
tour right now right I gave up a quarter
of my year 90 days I hit 23 cities and
do the thing that I'm most afraid to do
which is get up and potentially
disappoint people every four days by
doing another event and I kept going
even though I broke my neck I broke my
neck three weeks ago in Denver and and
we kept going I only canceled one event
completely and it just got up and kept
going and so having that cause feeling
like the work that you do is important
and meaningful is the whole thing rule
number 20 be practical your vision alone
is not enough doing what you love is the
number one rule for Success from
everybody that I've covered but doing
what you love following your vision is
not enough you need to balance it with
what actually works this is why so many
people fall down and fail if you just
have a vision but don't pay attention to
the trends your vision will never happen
it will will die within you is Simon's
vision is to help people be inspired to
go to work I love it that's awesome I'm
on the same page that is a joint Vision
amazing but how you go about doing it
matters he's not doing it through smoke
signals in Myspace right that era is
gone but he's also not doing it through
virtual reality and hologram Simon's
coming into your living room right that
era has not arrived yet how you approach
the work matters so how does Simon do it
he does it mostly through his books
right start with why he does it through
his speaking the Ted Talk that launched
his whole career right how did Simon get
his mission to take off how did Simon
get people even aware about his vision
well he started by doing it just helping
his friends right he was he was just
being a good friend helping them out and
he said you should go and speak and then
he created that Ted Talk and he blew up
he blew up through his Ted X talk that
became a TED Talk and YouTube and then
through his books right if he was not
paying attention to the trends if he did
not go do his Ted talk if you did not
get on YouTube if he did not write the
book if it was not Marketing in the era
that we are in right now if he was not
paying attention to the trends that oh
people watch YouTube videos oh people go
to Ted Talks oh people read books if he
wasn't paying attention to those Trends
nobody would know Simon sinek that's the
problem
you start with a vision 100 just paying
attention to the trends is not enough
you start with the vision
but you have to know the trends too it's
always both rule number 21 work hard
hard work is your ticket in it doesn't
guarantee your success there are tons of
people who work hard and are living at
the poverty line but there is nobody who
wins and doesn't work hard working hard
is your ticket in one of the biggest
reasons why I've won on YouTube is
because I've been making three videos a
day for the past five plus years three
videos a day for five plus years there
there have been one or two days where
maybe I missed one video not three
videos not an entire day off maybe one
video once or twice in five years that's
it
it's just been a testament to
consistency every single day videos have
to go live on the channel and I filmed
through everything I film through having
broken my neck right in two spots I've
filmed through having a concussion I
filmed through being sick I filmed
through completely losing my voice and
then having to to pull up pieces of
paper with the notes written on it I
filmed through everything I think
there's a lot of people who who I look
up to who I think are way better than me
people who have way more Talent than me
who are way more natural than I am at
making videos and expressing themselves
and I've passed them because I just
worked harder because I just kept going
because I kept making the content one of
the biggest reasons why you are not more
successful is you're just not
consistently working hard enough at it
this game of Entrepreneurship whether
you're trying to be a YouTuber or
something totally different it's are you
getting up every single day and doing
the thing that you have to do because
you're gonna get punched in the face
there's gonna be so many setbacks rule
number 22 raise your environment your
environment is keeping you where you are
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you exactly where you
are right now the people you listen to
the media that you consume the habits
that you do daily all of them all of
them are designed to keep you exactly
where you are so if you want to raise
your game if you want to raise your life
you need to raise your environment I've
changed a lot over the course of having
this YouTube channel the people who've
known me the best and the longest
especially in the past two to three
years have said Evan you've changed a
lot for the better you've evolved you're
more confident you have more more Poise
you're a better speaker you you're
pushing the boundaries more you've
changed what happened
how do I get that for myself right
people wanted it whenever you are off
growing and learning and evolving other
people they want it they want a taste of
it they want to do it too because we are
not designed to just photocopy Our Lives
over and over and over again so how did
I get it I paid more attention to my
environment I paid more attention to my
daily routines I paid more attention to
the people that I hang around with
it's important so looking at my physical
environment right look at the look at
this office look at the people behind me
this all means something to me looking
at the new design that I've had here
below putting things like my neck braces
it's down below you can't really see it
but this inspires me I walk into this
every day
my YouTube videos the channel I create
for myself
that the people that I profile I'm
learning from I feel like I have garyvee
in my head I have Oprah Winfrey in my
ear I've got Elon Musk tell me what to
do pushing me to try to get better I
hear these people talking about you have
to be courageous you have to be bold you
have to believe in yourself more and
when I feel myself being nervous about
something boom boom boom boom boom it's
a push that I have to do it
and so I've designed my life I've
designed my environment to help push me
to get to the next step rule number 23
take action most people don't fail
enough most people are so afraid of a
huge fail that they don't even try
you're afraid of taking a big bet you're
afraid of going into deep debt and that
fear prevents you from having the thing
that matters the most right now in your
business
momentum you don't need to fail big but
you do need to start otherwise you will
never build the big business that you're
capable of building so I'm a big fan of
going from idea to action idea to action
idea to action idea to action get an
idea what do you do you take action
teach yourself train yourself as soon as
you get that idea don't judge it don't
think about it don't plan and Ponder and
strategize because your list of ideas is
a mile long and it's not going to get
any shorter you're a genius you come up
with great ideas you're going to keep
coming with ideas for the rest of your
life that list of ideas is not going to
shrink
so how do you start moving you take
action I call the two percent difference
instead of planning to get the hundred
percent for your idea what's the two
percent difference that you can just do
something about right now I think your
ideas came to you for a reason I think
it's inspired why are you thinking about
this thing don't judge the reason just
go off and do something one small
conversation one small action start
building momentum that's the thing
that's missing right now is momentum you
need more momentum you're a genius you
have great ideas you should be changing
the world what's missing is momentum and
I want you to find it rule number 24
love what you do this is why it's so
important that you love what you do
success is painful it's a lot of work a
lot of stress a lot of failure a lot of
rejection but the thing that gets you
through it is you love what you do you
love the process you love the work you
love the growth if you don't love the
work you do you will give up because it
will just become too painful to keep
going so at the Whole Foods morning when
I went to go get my Bulletproof Coffee I
ran into a friend of mine an
entrepreneur friend of mine who I told
about my tour in December before I left
and she was super excited and I had it
connected with her since I got back I
went on this three month 90 day 23 City
Tour across the us and it was amazing
happened since to meet her at the Whole
Foods this morning and she said how's
the toy what was the best part of it
and I said breaking my neck
two-thirds of the way through I broke my
neck I broke my neck in two spots I
compressed my spine I had a concussion
had to get Staples in my head all of it
she said
breaking your neck that's the best part
of your tour well that's a really
positive outlook
it's not just a positive outlook
it's the best like it actually was the
best part
because it really got the test like why
this sounds crazy but this is it this is
this is the process this is the mindset
shift I want you guys to make that you
do difficult things you love difficult
things you don't want it to be easy easy
means you're inside your comfort zone
easy means you're not pushing up against
any barriers you don't want to be easy
stop getting these easy small tiny wings
that you can snack on you do difficult
things you love taking on Amazing huge
things that's who you are that's what
you do
and this was a chance for me to grow and
help cement that for myself rule number
25 don't make busyness your habit most
people are crazy busy but don't get
anything done if you feel like you're
crazy busy like you barely have any
enough time for yourself that you get to
the end of the week and you know you've
been you've been hauling ass all week
long you've been you've been busting
your face in you've been working and
working and working super busy but then
you look back and you say what did I
actually do this week if that's you then
this message is for you you're busy but
you're not focused and shifting your
life begins with shifting your
priorities so I used to pride myself on
responding to email ASAP quickly like
you sent me an email 30 seconds to 60
seconds later you would get my response
I prided myself on like that's good
service that's what you should do as an
entrepreneur right like people
communicating with you you want to send
it back to them quickly I hated having
the weight and wait and wait on people
so I didn't want to be that for others
so I had all my notifications turned on
and as soon as an email came in ding
came in boom response go what made it
worse was people would then get my
response I tended to be on the computer
at the same time and then they read back
right away and say wow you're really
quick thank you so much and that fed
that fed the identity that fed the the
ego and I I am very fast exactly right
there's proof that this thing works
the problem was I wasn't getting
anything important done
I was working on something and then the
notification came in and I stopped what
I was working on to go answer this email
feel great about myself that little hit
and then come back to my project like
what was I working on and it takes time
to start getting back into the flow of
working on that thing and then another
email comes in and so I ended up being
busy I was working all day long all day
long right like
lunch at the desk breakfast at the desk
dinner at the desk all day long right
wash them back to the desk there was no
breaks all day long straight through but
when I get to the end of the day out of
the week like what did I do this week
I don't know
[Music]
but I answered a lot of emails
because they didn't have Focus I didn't
have priorities and when I realized that
after that happened enough times I
realized wow this isn't I'm never gonna
get close to my goals like just doing
this all I'm doing is reacting to other
people's goals when somebody shoots me
an email that's what they want they're
demanding my time
and I'm giving it to them freely because
I have no defense around my time because
I I have no respecter on time I'm just
letting it bleed out there's no time for
me to work on what I want and so I'm not
going to make any progress on the things
that I want if you want to make progress
on the things that you want you have to
carve out time for the things that you
want that's how it works and you got to
put Gates and blockades and barriers
around and say this is my focus time and
nobody's allowed in now worst case
emergencies family awesome but there
aren't that many actual emergencies
you have to be willing to let the small
balls drop
to go for the big goals in your life you
have to pick you can't do both really
well you have to pick what do you want
to be great at do you want to be great
at getting every little small thing done
and then never do the big thing or you
want to be great at getting the big
things done and risk losing some of the
small things because by chasing down the
big things
you're going to lose some small things
it's just gonna happen rule number 26
have a mission this is why I hate five
to ten year goals you are not going to
be the same person five years from today
as you are right now let alone 10 years
from today you won't be the same person
think of the person who you were five
years ago go back five years from today
five years subtract five years from
today's date go back to that person
could that person accurately predict
what a happy successful joyous impactful
life is for who you are right now could
that person five years ago actually
predict what you today are capable of
heck no
heck no not if you've been growing none
of you've been learning not if you've
been experiencing life you're capable of
so much more today than you ever thought
was possible five years ago and so what
makes you think that the person who you
are right now can accurately predict
what you're going to love doing what
you're going to be great at your goals
your plans for the next five to ten
years it's not possible you're thinking
small here's the thing I think you could
have a five-year plan or a 10-year plan
and hit it it's just small compared to
what you are actually capable of doing
because you put the blinders on you stay
down this one course but the best course
for moves actually going to swing out
here
but you are so stubborn and so focused
Focus can be a great thing but can also
lead you to play small for Life instead
of having five or ten year goals I want
you to replace them with a mission Rule
Number 27 Focus the problem is not that
you're not a genius the problem is not
that you don't have great ideas the
problem is that you are not focused you
haven't said that this is the thing this
is what I have to accomplish today this
is the mission that I am on and nothing
is going to stop me if you don't learn
the focus on what's important to you
you'll never do important things and
live your life reacting to what's
important to other people instead so I
recently started a new business with one
of my thought Leadership Academy
students Jeremy he came to my event last
year I was thinking about him on my tour
this year and said I want to start a
business with Jeremy around YouTube
Consulting I get asked a lot hey Evan
can you check out my channel hey Evan
can I work with you Haven can I hire you
for XYZ looking at my channel giving me
ideas mentoring guiding me and it's just
not the business that I want to be the
end but it is a business and so I
thought Jeremy Jeremy's going to come on
board he's going to do it now when I
recruited him and called him he was not
a YouTube expert and I gave him the
homework and said listen if you want to
do this business together it's got to be
important to you I'm halfway through my
trip on my tour I'm coming back in a
month and a half here's what I need you
to know by the end of the month and a
half and I gave him resources I gave him
videos I gave him insights and analytics
and said you need to know all of this
know all of this and then when I come
back if you're ready we'll start the
business
he did he focused he made it his
priority he knew nothing about this and
all of a sudden he became an expert by
every day all day long grinding to learn
by researching everybody who was an
expert at this understanding their
methodologies their best practices
looking through all my videos my
thumbnails my strategies all the things
that I've talked about in the past
digesting it kind of like the Matrix
when Neo is in The Matrix and and he now
he can learn Kung Fu and now he learns
how to fly a helicopter all of that
stuff that's basically what he did and
when it came back in a month and a half
put him to the test and said hey let's
do two free calls we'll take two people
from my community and say hey free free
call let's go and he blew me away with
how much he knew because he focused on
it he was a guy he went from knowing
almost zero
to now being an expert
to be able to really help give value to
people
and now when we're looking at new people
coming in
I barely have to do anything
because he already knows what I'm gonna
say he already knows he's already done
the work he's done the research because
he spent that time on focused effort and
this is where I think a lot of people
feel like they're never going to win
because you may not have had the
expertise you don't have the education
it doesn't take long to become an expert
it's just focused work that you're
passionate about
focused work you could quickly become in
a matter of months and expert at
something if you just focus in on it and
dedicate your life to that thing
that you love you can easily pass people
who are experts at something who don't
love their thing
but because you're willing to take it on
you're willing to absorb think about
when you went to school how much of the
information you had in your head but you
had to read over the page four times
so if you're at the same page four or
five six times because you got lost you
got distracted that's not focused work
because you don't love that thing
but when you love something how much
faster do you retain it how much more
enjoyable is the learning process how
much better are you really quickly
because you love doing that thing
and so Jeremy got really good really
quickly because he loved it because he
attacked it because he focused on
because he made it a priority because he
didn't say well I'll spend half an hour
a week trying this new thing no that's
not how you win
now where do we go from here we'll see
does Jeremy want to be a one-man band
forever does he just want to be a high
paid consultant does he want to then
bring on a team does he want to expand
do you want to have products we'll see
we'll see how that business evolves and
flows
but he got here in a really short amount
of time because of that focused effort
and energy and that's what I want for
you run rule number 28 let you let your
Genius
choices in
chase your dreams and risk upsetting
some people who don't get it or Choice
number two play small for life and never
do what you're capable of because you're
afraid of what some people will say
about you most people play small and
live a life of regret I want to put
pressure on you today to step into your
fear and step into your potential so
yesterday I shot a 10-part series with
Neil pasricha he is an author who sold
over a million books and I did a 10 part
series I said Neil I have a series on
how to make a million dollars in
different Industries I want to do a 10
part series with you on how to sell a
million books you've done it most people
have never come even close I want to
pick your brain dissect it understand
what makes people successful and how to
sell a million books and he said
yesterday on camera that his default
reaction was who am I to do this I mean
I just got lucky
yeah I I don't know how I did it and and
he was afraid to come on and actually
share some of his tips because most
people don't ask him this question so
I've never been asked this question
before I don't know how to respond I'm
afraid of coming on camera on the
YouTube channel with you a friend of
mine and and looking dumb and having
nothing to say
and because that was part of the reason
he had to go off and do it and so he
came up with a list of 10 things he came
up with his idea he said no I'm I work
hard Neil's one of the hardest working
authors of all time Neil is constantly
working constantly grinding constantly
finding new opportunities to write books
and promote his books he got there not
out of just luck
he got there because he worked really
hard at it and I pulled out those
lessons from him and that's the mindset
that I want people to take that's what I
want you to take
that you're not in your situation
because you're lucky you're good
you could be better you could still grow
more but your Genius you're talented
you're amazing and you need to let that
shine you need to let that out
and some people may watch you they may
watch your videos they may read your
books they may see what you produce and
say this person is so full of themselves
this person doesn't get it like you're
not going to appeal to everybody even me
even my message I'm not a controversial
guy right my messages believe how do you
hate them believe people do
right I'm not I'm not coming out with my
channel and saying this person sucks and
talking politics and all these things
that you know are going to trigger
people right that's not who I am I want
to spread belief and yet even though I
think we've got one of the best
communities uh online in the YouTube
Community people are often toxic on
different channels but shout out believe
Nation fist bump love you guys it's it's
positivity and yet we still have people
who are negative they don't get it
they want to spread negativity in my
community and so what do I do should the
answer be well I'm not going to post
content because I'm worried about what
this person's gonna say should I not
post content because I'm not I'm not
happy with the end result I mean it was
350 videos I made public before I was
wasn't completely embarrassed by my
content embarrassed like I couldn't
watch it back I was so embarrassed like
oh it's so bad it's so bad it's so bad
post
next move on to the next one and with
practice and repetition you get better
I've done 6 000 something videos so it
took me a long time to get there you
might be able to get there a lot faster
but it's very rare that you start off
and the first thing you do pops and even
if it does don't expect everybody to
love it you're gonna get people who will
not like what you do rule number 29 just
try your hardest you need to tie self
respect to your effort
where you get yourself love from
yourself respect your self-confidence
should not come from winning it comes
from trying because if you tie yourself
respect to winning you'll only do things
that you know you're gonna win at and
therefore you play small for life so I'm
training the guy on my team who I've
promoted and I'm putting them in a
position that is Way Beyond his skill
set Way Beyond what he thought he'd be
doing and it's a big push outside his
comfort zone there was a guy who was
doing a bunch of admin tasks for me and
now he's in charge of all of my YouTube
analytics I want him to be my data guy I
want him to go through the thousands of
videos I have on my channel and make
recommendations to say this intro is too
long this intro is too short this
thumbnail sucks you know when you talk
Evan things blow up or things suck when
you wear black people love it anything
go through all the data go through all
the analytics and tell me where we need
to make improvements so I was on a call
with him yesterday
[Music]
and I had to have a serious talk with
them because he's looking for data that
supports his hypothesis because he
suggested on my channel my main channel
that we go back to my original intros
where I say
one sentence here one sentence here and
one sentence here and then he's Robert F
Smith and here's my take on his top 10
rules of success right that's what we
did way back like in the very first
original series of the top tens and
we've evolved so
he suggested take out the song Take out
the intro take out a whole bunch of
stuff I'm used to those three things and
let's see if it works so that's what I
did like great good idea the data
supported it backed it up let's go and
try we haven't tried it we won't know so
we tried it the first video came up was
the Robert F smith top 10 rules of
success on that new template
and I'm looking at the data in it and it
sucked you know my goal is to get 70
artist retention at one minute that's
when that's my goal across my channels
70 honest retention at one minute that
means 30 of people Max have left at the
one minute Mark that's an insanely High
goal to reach almost nobody hits that
especially consistently you might think
oh 70 it's easy it's it's insanely
difficult in the YouTube world so I
looked at the numbers for this one and
it was 52 or something something brutal
we haven't we don't really operate in
the 52 range so this one came in it was
brutal 52 like having a heart attack oh
suck people hate this
and then I asked him hey how are we
doing on the new videos and he sent me
this report that says hey well on our
relative data is up you know a relative
of data saying compared to all videos on
YouTube this video is doing well in the
first minute
yeah but that's that's not actually the
real story because all of our videos
relative to regular YouTube if they're
looking at any video this video and even
my first video all of them every video I
make relative to a normal average
YouTube video were higher relative
that's not what I'm looking for we're
going after 70 audience retention at one
minute you know this this is where we're
focused
[Music]
behind all of it was he just didn't want
to feel like a failure
he didn't want to feel like he
recommended something to me and it
didn't work out
that is trying to justify it by saying
well look this stat shows that it works
but it's not what we're after this
experiment so far has been an epic
failure and that's okay what I need you
to do is expect to suck expect the ideas
not to work nope know that coming in
know that coming in we're already
operating a really high level
right if every experiment that we try
works that means that we just sucked at
the beginning right we sucked
you're learning you're picking this up
most of my new experiments don't work
I'm trying hundreds of new things all
the time and most of them won't work I
expect to suck but it's okay because I
tie myself forth to the effort am I
putting my Max effort out your
experiment I'm talking to the guy your
experiment was a great test I backed it
the data suggested we do it but it's not
working
and we'll give it a month to see and if
it still doesn't work we're going to
move on to do something else
believe that you have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something that you are a
genius you are the best the best at
something most people either one have no
idea what that thing is or two they have
found it but they don't have the courage
or belief to go chase it down either way
the path is through you need to find the
thing that you are a genius at that you
have Michael Jordan level Talent at and
live it every single day if you want to
live your life instead of regret your
life rule number 31 at attack the fear
people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you'll sing in the shower but you
won't sing on the street corner you'll
record a video but you'll never release
it you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time also be your
own biggest fan that needs to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people I'm terrified of
disappointing people the idea that you
would come to my thought Leadership
Academy and I would teach you how to win
on social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it the idea that that you would
come and be disappointed destroys me and
it's led to some positive things and
that I always over deliver I'm always
obsessed I'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10 of
the value I'm giving you still more than
made the money that you invested into
any of the stuff that I'm doing but at
the same time it's still this fear and
so I want to attack the fear I teach
myself to attack the fear and I think
you should too even just attacking it
for the sake of attacking it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business it's good
because you're building strength because
you're pushing your comfort zone because
you're getting better because you're
growing that's worth something that's a
ton of value because if you can conquer
your fear of doing this one thing that
translates to every of your life if you
teach yourself to have more courage that
translates everywhere
so maybe you're afraid of if you're on a
cruise ship and they they bring up
couples and they do a game show you're
afraid of what might happen on that game
do it
how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur because
that's the same fear that you face in
your business that fear of going on that
game show on the cruise ship that fear
of taking your phone and recording a
video in public on the street these
fears that seem like nothing they show
up everywhere in your life they show up
everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes
starts building the muscle rule number
32 believe you go as far as you believe
you can go when the people around you
say you're crazy when you're putting in
massive effort but you're not getting
the results where you sit alone and
wonder did you just make the biggest
mistake of your life by starting this
business that is the time when most
people quit and you need to believe more
because if you love this thing if you
know that it's going to impact people
and you give up too soon you will regret
for the rest of your life knowing that
you were capable of more and you just
quit on it a little too early so I look
at my new book as an example I did my
tour Across America met with
entrepreneurs all across America and
found that people were struggling with
the same thing they want to know how do
I find what my purpose is and turn it
into a lucrative business
every city that I went to even though
that was not the topic I was covering it
came up over and over and over and over
again 23 different cities and so I
thought I'm going to write a book on
this this is going to be my next book
I'm going to take people through the
process because my process works and it
helped people live in in 10-15 minutes
and they're getting they're getting new
ideas and and results and here we go
like they understand what path they need
to take finally they have Clarity on
what to do next and so I told my agent
and my lit agent like this is the next
book I want to write
[Music]
Publishers is the next book I'm going to
write
and from the start it's been this big
pull it's been it's been fighting it's
we don't like the title we don't like
the concept no we're not going to
publish it no we're not going to publish
it and I want to do it by January
because I want to do my next tour across
the rest of the United States East Coast
Texas Mexico I want to do my next tour
so I want to have my book in stores by
that time and it's been this rough slog
where if I didn't believe in myself that
this was so important with the people
who are looking at it saying no we don't
like this concept now it's been written
before now this method we don't believe
in
it's easy to quit it's easy to give up
it's easy to say forget it I just know
that it's gonna work
I know that the process helps people
I've seen it with my eyes across 23
cities over 90 days
I wrote the draft of the book and I gave
it to some beta readers and the number
one piece of advice from people who've
read both my books the you're one word
and then this like this is this is the
better book this is the best book you've
written so far including my
self-published ones and so what do I do
I've got these people who are my
audience who love it and then these
people who aren't my audience but who
make decisions saying now we don't
believe in it
I'm not gonna call it
quit I gotta keep going I gotta do my
tour
there's there better be some crazy good
reason for me not to do my tour right
even if I have to self-publish it no I'm
pretty close to making my deal making it
all happen and and getting timelines and
all that but we don't have a signed
contract yet and anything can happen
we're pushing the timelines because I'm
pushing the timelines because otherwise
this thing could drag on forever when
you have an idea that you love that you
know can have a huge impact
that's just taking longer than you hoped
it would when people are telling you
that it's crazy and that it's stupid and
that who are you to go off and do this
thing
you love it you have you have to double
down on it you have to go in on it you
have to be open to getting help but if
that door closes you try to find another
one and that's the story of every
successful person you're trying to do
something different rule number 33
become a shark you haven't become a
shark yet because you haven't decided
that your mission is important enough
now being a shark doesn't mean that you
have to become aggressive violent and
angry it means that you're pushing to be
the best in your industry a true leader
someone who makes a difference and it
starts with your mission raise the level
of how important your mission feels to
you and your entire life changes so I
look at my mission as an example I want
to solve the world's biggest problem
it's never going to happen I'm trying to
solve the biggest problem I think in the
world which is that lack of belief in
yourself the untapped potential that's
what I wake up every day trying to do
and the more that I put myself in a
position of this thing matters what I do
really really matters the more I could
put myself in that mind frame the bigger
my thinking becomes the Bolder I get as
a human and as an entrepreneur and I
look at the path that I've taken over
the past X number of years I look at
being able to collaborate with someone
like Eric Thomas when he gave a shout
out in his video that would have been
something I wouldn't have thought of
when I first started on YouTube I look
at the relationships I built with people
like Tony Robbins and Gary vaynerchuk
and Grant Cardone the people that we
profile Tony Robbins I took the people
on my team to go see him and Unleash the
Power Within I brought five I think of
my people down and we're sitting up in
the cheap seats and then a year later a
year later he invited me as his personal
guest to sit right down in the front row
chairman invited seating and I'm going
back I leave tomorrow I don't know when
this video goes up but I leave tomorrow
for Dallas to do it again
it's wild
right like it doesn't feel like that
stuff is possible
comes from shift in the value of your
your mission I deserve it because what
I'm doing is solving a real problem
and we often feel like we're not capable
of doing these great things and we
downplay our role and we downplay how
important our mission is and we downplay
what we think we can do that's what
needs to shift that's what needs to
change you need to feel like the work
you do matters you need to feel like the
mission you're on means something can
have a big impact and if you're
approaching life in that way everything
in your business changes rule number 34
never quit on something that you love as
long as you love it you have to keep
going you cannot quit maybe one day
somebody does throw you a bunch of money
and you can stop sleeping in your office
or maybe it's just a slow grind up and
it takes you 10 years to become an
overnight success you'll never know how
long it will take you to be successful
but what you do know is that if you quit
on something that you love you will end
up regretting it for the rest of your
life as long as you love it you have to
keep going you can't quit so look at my
story it wasn't easy being an
entrepreneur aren't growing up that's
why I do so much to help entrepreneurs
because I don't want you guys to
struggle as much as I did in my first
real business when I was 19 I had to
decide between earning a hundred
thousand dollars a year and travel
around the world in my dream job versus
only 30 of a company making 300 bucks a
month and being unsure if anything's
gonna work out or not and I decided that
I had to keep going I had to try because
I didn't want to end up being 85 years
old looking back and said I never did it
I never went for it I would rather no
one fail than not know because the
things that you regret are rarely the
things that you do it's the things that
you didn't do the things that you had a
chance to do you had an opportunity you
thought about it you felt it but then
you back down because you're afraid
those are the things that you regret
that's what you regret most I didn't
want that to happen
but starting off my business wasn't easy
I struggled I suck I I made it harder on
myself because I told my friends that I
was living the entrepreneur life and I
couldn't hang out with them meanwhile
that twenty dollars was just too
expensive for me to go out and have beer
with them
I isolated myself I made myself lonely
I felt worthless as a human being and
the worst day of my life came when I
told my business partner that I quit on
him that it was just too difficult that
I I couldn't keep going that I needed to
feel like I was contributing that that
my time meant something that all this
work I was putting into something I just
need to feel valuable again that I was
contributing to something because when
you wake up every day and you're working
and it's just not getting results it can
be real hard to keep going
and so I told him that I quit I hung up
the phone and then just started crying
and the next day I woke up and I just
thought I can't I can't I can't quit on
this not yet I haven't given everything
I've got
because I felt like
in a year and two years and five years
and 20 years I would look back and
regret that I gave up
if I knew that I gave everything I had
and it didn't work out I was okay with
the failure
it was just an idea of that thing
lingering that I could have given a
little bit more that I still like this
thing and I needed to see it through and
I and I didn't that I quit on it I knew
that would eat me up forever
and so I had to get up that next day and
tell myself I'm not going to quit yet I
just have to find a different way to
stand what I've tried so far has not
worked it has not worked I'm making zero
money well 300 bucks a month
but it's not working out and I hate
myself I hate my life I hate how I feel
about myself I have to find a different
way to stand
and that energy allowed me to keep going
that energy allowed me to then ask
myself who else has done this before and
I looked at Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft and that started the
path up for my business and then two
years later I sold my company it
happened pretty quick
all because I refuse to quit on the
thing that I knew I needed to see
through rule number 35 unlock your
talent
Jordan level
instead of being world class at that
thing you settled for being just above
average at something that you should not
be doing Albert Einstein once said
everybody is a genius but if you judge a
fish by its ability to climb a tree it
will believe its whole life that it is
stupid that's most people's problems you
are a fish and you're trying to climb a
tree instead of going and being great at
swimming this is the exact problem that
I'm on a mission to solve so I recently
had a young entrepreneur come to one of
my Toronto q a meetups that are free
that I host every week and he said Evan
I have a problem I'm trying to decide
between what my parents want me to be
which is an architect and what I feel a
yearning towards which is being a
musician and I don't know what to do
I know how to decide I don't know how
I'm going to be a success as a musician
I don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and this is clearly the fine
path for how to do it and he's afraid
and I think that's so many people
there's a safe perfect path that has
been designed that people have done
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever or this is new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people and you do what they want
you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it
it's never been easier to actually be
yourself and build a business and have
success being uniquely you right this
was not open to your parents and
definitely not your grandparents the
ability to be an entrepreneur on the
side making money using your phone is
something that your grandparents don't
understand it's just it's totally wild
and so you are a unique individual right
you are I am we all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems you're unique you need to do
something unique if you are unique you
need to do something unique if you're
stuck doing the same thing that somebody
else wants you to do you're never going
to be happy now there may be some
alignment you may not absolutely hate
the job that you're at but you know
you're capable of more you're Michael
Jordan you are the Michael Jordan of
something you're a genius and absolute
Bonafide genius at something this is why
I think it's the world's greatest
problem this is why I do what I do every
single day in making this content videos
for you because I want to unlock people
hope hopefully more than one at a time
but even if it's just one person who
watches this video and gets unlocked I'm
pumped because I think if everybody is
off doing the thing that they are a
genius at man I want to live in that
world rule number 36 keep up with the
change every time YouTube updates their
algorithm you should be pumped anytime
Facebook LinkedIn Instagram makes an
update you should celebrate because this
is your chance to win as an entrepreneur
everybody else who's ahead of you who've
made it on the old algorithm before the
update happened they're complaining and
wishing that it goes back to the way
that it used to be it's not going back
and the faster you can get on that train
and understand how the new algorithm
works you are going to soar past
everybody else whenever something new
comes along it's gonna happen guys the
new things that are coming along is only
going to speed up there's going to be
more new things not fewer new things
every time a new thing comes along you
don't necessarily need to be the first
one on it I'm not saying that you have
to go off and try try everything but
when something new is coming along
embrace it because this is the future
right so many people say well I'm not on
social media oh that's for the kids
you've got to get on it if you're an
entrepreneur you need to be on social
media and not just giving it off to your
kid or your niece or your nephew to do
you you need to understand it doesn't
mean you need to be the best at it but
you need to understand it because this
is not just where marketing is going
it's where marketing is your business is
suffering because you don't understand
how to play the game so Rome wasn't
built in a day but it didn't crumble in
a day either if you're not on social if
you're not taking advantage of new
technologies your business is slowly
starting to crumple and I don't want
that for you rule number 37 play to win
people are so afraid to lose that they
don't even try so when you have nothing
when you're at the bottom
takes as soon as you've won just a
little bit now you risk losing something
and this is where most people back down
and play small for life and so you need
to decide are you playing life to win or
you playing life afraid to lose so I
look at my YouTube channel as an example
when I started it there was no risk
nobody knew me nobody's watching my
videos I could go and fail didn't make a
difference I could try a whole bunch of
different things whenever the algorithm
changed I got pumped because the people
who are ahead of me were complaining and
would would be romantic and would want
it to go back the way it was and I'm
like hey algorithm change amazing let's
go I'm gonna learn that new thing
but now I've gotten bigger
right now I think I have more views than
anybody in The Entrepreneur Space on
YouTube and it's easy to now be
protective it's easy to say well I built
this thing I don't want to lose and I
hate that I need to I need to destroy
that I want to be constantly losing
constantly testing constantly risking
now not risking at all not not putting
everything on the line just for one
thing but to be willing to test willing
to fail as an example
I split up my channels
I split up my channels into eight
different channels I got an advice from
Matt Gillan he's one of five people who
who I put on my hand as people who I
listened to for YouTube advice right he
was one of the five and another one in
the five said don't do it so I got five
people who I listened to about YouTube
one person says split up your channel
one person says don't do it what do I do
I have to do it just to see because I
know what not splitting on my channel
looks like it's what I'm currently doing
but splitting on my channel I won't know
if it's gonna work or not until I
actually go off and do it and so I did
and here's a news flash it's not working
yet right my other channels the most I
think has 8 000 subscribers I have two
around 8 000 subscribers and the others
are smaller and they're growing every
day and they're getting a momentum every
day but overall my subscriber growth is
down My Views are down my revenue is
down everything is down it's all down
watch time is down everything is down is
it a big failure I don't know maybe I'm
gonna give it more time and see
I'm gonna give it more time and see it's
a risk right I went from making three
videos a day on one channel to making
one video a day across a couple channels
and then you know once a week on some
channels and we have eight different
channels now it's more headache it's
more management maybe ultimately it will
work out or maybe in six months I'll
come back and say man that was a giant
failure that sucked
but I won't know until they try and
that's that's where you need to risk it
that's where you need to try you need to
see you need to test you need to taste
it rule number 38 stop hiding the reason
why you are not further ahead is you
have told yourself that you are not
capable of it that's it and you'll come
up with really smart reasons that are
based in logic as to why you're not more
successful you are a genius you are
excellent and so you'll come up with
really Smart Genius reasons as to why
you are not further ahead right now but
at the end of the day you're just afraid
and you don't think you're capable
that's what I want to change in you
today so I sat down yesterday with an
entrepreneur who is an up and coming
entrepreneur he's had a job for a long
time he's now in his mid 50s and he got
let go from his job and he interviewed
for another job and it didn't feel it
was quite fit and and he didn't get the
job but he doesn't want to go back and
get another job he wants to now go do
his own thing but there's that gnawing
little voice in your head that says who
am I to do this who am I to be an
entrepreneur who am I to bring value to
others who am I to make money off this
idea why not just go play it safe and
get a job working with somebody else and
his one word was getting down to saying
yes like you have to say yes and so this
is where it's really important when you
know what you stand for when you know
what your core value is
whenever you see it and then you see
your life not aligned with it you're
going to be unhappy if you're unhappy if
you need more boldness more motivation
more confidence more courage look to
your most important core value look look
at what you stand for look at who you
are because if your one word is all
about saying yes to things then you have
to say yes right you have to go off and
do it because otherwise you'll live your
entire life in regret so here he is this
this entrepreneur who's now in his mid
50s who's been let go from his job who's
now trying to start up his own career
his own thing just got his first
speaking gig just getting started with
his YouTube channel and podcasts and
building momentum and that's what it's
all about he has all the skills he has
all the talents he's been in this
industry for decades he knows what he's
doing and yet he's afraid he's afraid
that he's not good enough he's afraid
that's not going to work out he's afraid
that people won't find his expertise his
knowledge valuable and I think that's
most people I think I think everybody's
a genius I think you're a genius I think
you have Michael Jordan level Talent
skills that's something you're just
doing the wrong thing and we're afraid
you're afraid to take action you're
afraid to do the thing and so you'll
live your entire life with regret
knowing that you are capable of more you
right now know you're capable of more
even if your friends and family and the
people around you say wow you're doing
such a good job you know you're capable
of more and you're not living up to your
potential
that's most people
and why are you not living up to your
potential because you're afraid of what
that means you're afraid of the
obstacles you have to overcome you're
afraid of the difficulties that you have
to go through you're afraid of being
judged you're afraid of a failure
happening and being catastrophic you not
be able to recover you're just afraid
and so we need to crush that we need to
crush that we need to teach yourself
that you do scary things rule number 39
concentrate on your effort most people
don't concentrate long enough on
achieving their goals so what happens
you don't achieve your goals if you're
focused on something and you do it every
day consistently you will eventually get
results but if you're constantly jumping
from one thing to another from one idea
to another from one activity to another
then you'll never actually accomplish
what you're capable of the problem isn't
lack of creativity or ideas or genius
it's a lack of concentration and if
that's you I want to fix it in this
video today so let's take a quick look
at my YouTube journey I started on
YouTube over 10 years ago it's crazy
it's been that long and I wasn't very
good when I started go back and watch my
first videos they're all still up there
I haven't deleted them you can go back
and watch every single one of them see
how much I sucked I'm an introvert this
is not natural for me it took a lot of
concentration a lot of focused effort
and 6 000 plus videos later here I am
why because I just kept going because I
kept focus on my mission on my objective
it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself 350
videos I had to have my sister come come
into the room with the camera focus on
me press record and then leave because I
couldn't film with her in the room and
that's my sister how is this guy going
to be a YouTuber and be on stage and
give speeches and be a thought leader
and deliver presentations if you can't
even do a simple video with your sister
in a room concentration focused effort
that's the key it's been every single
day we've been uploading videos we've
done three plus videos a day for the
past five years every single day I've
been sick videos went up I broke my neck
in two spots had a concussion videos
going up I lost my voice videos going up
all the time every single day for the
past five plus years it's been at least
three videos across my main Channel now
my multiple channels
concentration I'm not very good at this
the point of all this isn't to brag or
say look at me it's saying that I suck
that if I could do it so can you the
difference is I think a lot of you guys
are way more talented than I am but look
at Alex for example who works for me at
TDS he's just so much more naturally
gifted in front of the camera he's he's
funny he's charismatic a lot of the
stuff that I'm not and I've been slowly
grinding away getting better in front of
the camera so I think a lot of you guys
are actually better than me or better
than what I was and if if you just kept
going if you just kept working on it you
would you would improve and you would
have the results you're after you're
just not patient enough you're not
concentrated enough you're not putting
in the work every single day
this great story comes to mind that is
great and sad at the same time I was
meeting a friend in Orlando
another influencer
um
six years ago or so
and we met up and he said I'm gonna be
the next garyvee
okay great I love it pumped like let's
go I'm I'm just starting my YouTube
career really starting to take off and
he's wants to be his thing and he's
going to be the next influencer I love
it and then he posted something about a
year ago or so and he said
you know five years ago I met Evan at
this place in Starbucks in Orlando and I
told him I was gonna be the next garyvee
and he was on his career to build his
YouTube channel and fast forward now and
Evan's got you know a million million
and a half subscribers and I'm still
kind of where I was because I didn't put
in the work
and so that's what I don't want for you
right he just he has talent he's a
genius so are you he just didn't do the
five years of work that I did and he's
someone who's actually I think way more
charismatic than I am and so I don't
want that for you I want you to
concentrate on your effort which will
then lead to results I'm going to give
you a three-step process that you can
follow to help you get there Step number
one is flip patience and impatience
people have this really messed up view
on patients and inpatients I think
people are often impatient with the
results so you want the results
immediately the human nature you want it
immediately but you're very patient with
yourself if you look at what you're
doing every day like I'll do that
tomorrow you get an idea yeah I'll start
Monday I'll start next week I'll start
and I'll start next year fresh year
start off fresh all that right no you
flip it you flip it you flip patients
and impatience what I want you to do is
have patience with the results that the
results will come and in patience with
yourself that today matters today you're
watching this
this during the day you're watching this
today matters what you create today has
to mean something because if you
approached every day with massive
inpatience for yourself and your effort
and you did that every day you did the
work that you were proud of yourself for
your effort I promise you that the
results are going to come
but we'll take some time to get to your
big goals
you have big goals right you want to you
want to do something big you have big
Ambitions you don't want just some tiny
little win awesome that's going to take
some time even if you're hustling and
grinding and being proud of your effort
every single day it's going to take some
time so patience with the results and
massive impatience with yourself number
two is think big and act small
this is where I think a lot of
entrepreneurs get tripped up you need to
think big and act small so you have a
big Vision a big mission something that
you want to go off and change the world
my big thinking is I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right it's never
going to happen in my lifetime and yet I
wake up every day trying to tackle it
you want to have a big Vision the
problem with it though for some people
is that it means you don't start because
to make that big Vision happen you need
money you need investors you need camera
gear you need equipment you need a team
me you need all this stuff right just
keeps adding up all the stuff you need
and then you never start that's the
problem the reason why some dummies are
winning off of your idea instead of you
is because they just started because
they acted small so you think big and
that's the motivating dream that you're
chasing down every day and you act small
like what's the smallest thing that I
can do today just to start building
momentum because momentum is a thing
that is missing in most businesses you
have great ideas your Genius you're
talented I love what you're trying to do
it's amazing you need momentum momentum
every single day creating a little bit
more momentum to make that dream come
true think big act small and number
three is schedule for Success look at
your calendar success is your habits
right you want to make sure that your
actions map to your Ambitions the
actions that are in your calendar if you
did those things would help you
accomplish your goals your dreams your
Ambitions so if you're talking about
building a YouTube career amazing show
me in your calendar where every week
you're making time to make YouTube
videos if you want to be an author
awesome I'm pumped show me in your time
show me in your calendar where you've
blocked it out that you're gonna spend
time writing on your book most people
don't do it and then you allow All These
Little Things these distractions to pull
you away from the thing that you want to
be doing you you have to put the big
things into your calendar first and
block off the time and protect that time
and look at it from above and not just
your business your your personal stuff
too what's a good relationship look like
what's a good health situation for
yourself look like right habits put in
your calendar and then step above it and
look at the week that you're about to go
off and do look at your week ahead if
you did those things consistently would
it help you accomplish your goals and
for too many people it's no you're
living in reaction mode to other
people's emergencies and then you never
get to do the thing that you want to do
you got to defend your time you schedule
for Success so whatever your big goals
are what if you need to concentrate on
you need to make sure you're spending an
appropriate amount of time on it so that
you get good at it so you can start
getting results and making the impact
that you know you can make schedule for
Success rule number 40 ignore what
others think if you live your life based
off the opinions of other people you
will never do anything great take a look
at who you're worried about people who
are not happy with their life people who
never went and took their shot people
who spend their life complaining instead
of trying to change something is that
who you want to be so worried about what
they think about your decisions if
anything you want to do the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do you don't want their life so stop
living your life by their rules so I had
an amazing one-on-one with an
entrepreneur yesterday at my q a session
here in Toronto that I do weekly and I
feel for her she's such a talented
amazing gifted entrepreneur and we
talked about your purpose coming from
your pain and she went through some
massive pain that guided her to the
success right now and on her path to
personal development but she's afraid to
share what happened
and she said maybe in a year or two like
give me a year to work on it maybe I'll
share it because she's afraid of what
people will think she's afraid that if
it doesn't work out that she may not be
able to get another job she's afraid of
all these things that people might say
about her if they found her the truth
problem is that's your path I don't care
about what where you're at right now I
need to know where you've come from I
need to know that you look like me I
need to know that your story is like
mine and so by living in the shadows and
being afraid to tell the truth what
you're doing is one not letting people
connect you as a real person right this
fake perfect version of you isn't
something that people can connect to two
you make it so that whatever you went
through it you're telling yourself that
it's it's shameful and you're telling
other people that it's shameful too but
if you come out and talk about what
happened then the people who feel
ashamed about it they now can come out
and say ha I'm not the only one
this happens to other people too I'm a
little bit more normal and three if you
want to build a business if you want to
create a YouTube channel if you want to
have a podcast you want to be an author
you want to write a book that's the
thing that's going to actually help take
you off
that's the thing there was a a great
video that I told her about about a
woman who gained 70 pounds uh from
having a child so she's pregnant she
gained 70 pounds
and she had a 10 pound baby and now she
had 60 pounds of extra
fat on her right 60 pounds so that's a
lot and so she's trying to lose it and
she's working out and she's eating
healthy and she finally gets down to
having a six pack abs and looking great
and then somebody noticed that when she
bent over
that that they could see the flaps of
skin when she stood up it was all six
pack but when she bent over there was
flaps of skin and what most people would
have done is deleted that video pretend
like it didn't exist not talk about that
comments right only show the perfect
version look how much weight I lost but
she did something different and said she
said yeah
that's my body now that's what happens
when you gain 70 pounds in pregnancy and
pump out a 10 pound baby
and that became a rallying cry that one
moment of vulnerability of saying hey
I'm still not perfect like look look at
this saggy skin that I still have
that's what brought people to her now
she's not just another mom who lost
weight and did this workout plan and
meal plan right that that connection was
real and now she's built a Million
Dollar Plus business from selling
e-courses and her recipes and everything
else that she goes through that's the
thing
this is your competitive Advantage your
purpose your pain your story is your
competitive Advantage I do not want to
learn from you until I know that you've
been through what I'm going through
I can't relate to that story right I
can't tell that story I can't tell a mom
who gained 70 pounds how to lose weight
that's not my story I can't relate to it
but helping entrepreneurs I can because
I struggled and I suffered and I was
making 300 a month and I was eating the
same bean salad lunch every day and I
celebrated with only McDonald's french
fries because I couldn't afford to buy
it all of it I struggle with with fear
and embarrassment and and shame all of
it I know what it's like I've been
through that and why I do what I do now
is because I want to try to make the
path a little bit easier for the next
generation of entrepreneurs for you I
want you to feel like you're not alone I
want you to feel like there's a place
you can come to with a beautiful
community of believe Nation where we're
supporting each other and this content
every single day across multiple
channels that you can go and digest and
dive into and hopefully hopefully
hopefully make your path just a little
bit easier because I wish I had this
when I was getting started when I was a
19 year old entrepreneur who was
insecure and and ashamed and embarrassed
and not willing to talk to anybody about
the problems I was going through right
that's the thing that will connect
people to you but if you're so afraid of
what people's judgments are going to be
you're never going to get started I
believe humans are built to serve you're
built to serve you want to help other
people it's hardwired into US studies
show that the impact of serving other
people has the same effect on your brain
as food and sex it's hardwired into you
you want to help other people and at the
same time you're afraid of judgment so
how do you help other people if you're
also afraid of judgment it's it's having
your foot on the gas going to break at
the same time you know you're capable of
more but then you just standing on the
same spot it's the worst and so you have
to let go of the opinions of other
people some people may not like what
you're doing that's okay that can't
prevent you from service that can't
prevent you from fulfilling your mission
that can't prevent you from living the
life you want because you're going to be
95 years old looking back on your life
and regretting it knowing you're capable
of more but never taking action rule
number 41 focus on the effort everything
in your life changes when you learn to
tie your self-worth to your effort
instead of the results most people tie
their self-worth to the results to
winning you
think then you're screwed because that
person only takes on projects that you
know you have a pretty high chance of
winning at and therefore you play small
for Life the key is to tie your
self-worth to the effort to trying and
if you do that well you'll win Beyond
Your Wildest imaginations so let's use
me as an example look at this video
right here this video two minutes before
getting on and making this video
I'm nervous
I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why
I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore nope that's not
it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through I put this
pressure on myself to say this video
right now has to be the best video that
I've ever made that's my intention going
in to every time I'm filming most days I
don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and Bolder most the
time you won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie my self-worth my respect to
the effort I'm trying and every now and
then you'll make a bit of a breakthrough
you get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another win and
another win and so the answer isn't have
a big goal and then find a reason why
you can't do it the answer isn't dream
big and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
abilities to get up and try again and
try again and try again and pat yourself
on the back for the effort you're
putting in not just when you're winning
rule number 42 find your drive most
people quit on things because they don't
have a powerful Mission or they don't
know where their Drive comes from
chasing an opportunity isn't enough
because you're going up against people
who love that thing who might be willing
to die for that thing if you want to go
to Mars you're competing against Elon
Musk who would die to go to Mars you
better absolutely love it or he's going
to crush you you need to find the thing
that you love that does not feel like
work otherwise you'll end up working
your entire life and hating it so every
Thursday when I'm in Toronto I do this
free event for Toronto entrepreneurs at
my dance studio trying to dance salsa
five to six pm Thursdays when I'm in the
city I do a free event q a session for
an hour come out out meet me talk let's
hang out however I can help give back to
the community and help local
entrepreneurs my Thursdays are Bonkers
my Thursdays are all day long interviews
Hangouts podcasts Skype sessions
one-on-ones my assistant books them in
25 minute chunks and I have 25 minutes
on five minute break in between usually
I use that break to get set up for the
next one 25 minutes 5 25 5 25 5 the
whole day long and then I end up going
to the studio I record my podcast with
Mark Drager I then do two 30-minute
one-on-ones that we filmed for the
YouTube channel and then after all of
that I do a one hour q a for the
entrepreneur community and then after
that I'm doing more meetings with my
team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
Thursday how do you have the energy for
all of that stuff
I love it like I I love
the best for me I love it I'm not
getting paid for it it's free it's
probably not a great use of my time if I
if I had to pick for one hour what's the
best use of my time hang out with
startup entrepreneurs ask me their
questions or or do something like write
my book or make my next course or
something else it probably doesn't make
the most sense but I love it and so
therefore it makes the most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be torture and it
should be for me to jump into your
schedule should be torture I should look
at your calendar and say that's
ridiculous how do you have so much
energy for all that stuff and when you
jump in the mind it's like the exact
same for me when I gear up for Thursday
as an example when I put my extrovert
hat on I gain energy as the day goes on
I'm not losing energy by the time I hit
five o'clock and I'm doing the group
session with people I'm carrying the
energy of all the entrepreneurs that
I've met on my 25 minute one-on-ones
throughout the entire day
I love it I gain more steam but most
things ask me to do almost anything else
for for 8 10 12 14 hours I would hate my
life Aspen to make coffee for for 10
hours a day I would hate my life ask me
to play piano ask me to do almost
anything for that amount of time I would
hate my life because it feels like work
and so you have to find a thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it it actually gives you
energy so paying attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh
oh this sucks like that's a good signal
that you're doing the wrong thing
because you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are a genius you
should be crushing it at something and
if the work that you're doing is
draining your energy the people around
you are draining your energy chances are
you're in the wrong spot you're hanging
them with the wrong people you're doing
the wrong kind of work rule number 43 do
difficult things self-esteem comes from
doing difficult things you set a goal
you said you'd start doing something and
maybe even you do actually start doing
that thing but then you hit a roadblock
then it gets difficult it gets hard and
what you do in that moment will Define
the rest of your life when it's hard
when it's difficult do you rise to the
occasion or do you let yourself off
again finding some really logical reason
why you can't do that thing it doesn't
count until it's hard you don't grow
until it's hard you don't build
self-respect self-esteem self-confidence
until it's hard and you follow through I
keep these in my office as a reminder of
who I am of who I am in my best moments
my best self to push me to do more and
to push harder what what are these if
you're new to my channel welcome I'm
Evan uh I went on a tour at the
beginning of this year I did a tour of
23 cities 90 days and two-thirds of the
way through with a month left I broke my
neck when I was in Denver I fainted I
fell out of a chair I hit my head
against the wall cracked my the back of
my head open I had three Staples on my
head I had a concussion and I broke my
neck in two spots and after that night I
had to wear this I had to wear this for
the next
I just noticed this note here Nina
signed it
I love you get well soon Nina she signed
it that's that's sweet
ah gotta go thank her anyway had a
little emotional moment there I broke my
neck and I decided to keep going on my
tour I had a month left everybody was
telling me to go home my agent told me
to go home my friends my family said
come home get get the health care you
need relax stay in bed rest you need to
recover and I said
being with entrepreneurs is my recovery
and pushing through and doing this tour
is my healing one physical healing
because just sitting on the bed all day
is not going to be for someone like me
something that's amazing but two just
just push it through and knowing that I
can right it doesn't count until it's
hard it doesn't count until it's
difficult and then you get up and you do
it and so if you've seen any of the
videos or pictures of me at the events I
went from
standing up and moving around and having
energy to then I had to sit at the front
of a room with pillows behind me and an
ice pack on my shoulder blade for three
and a half four hours in massive pain
the whole time answering questions and
doing my workshop and I was so proud of
myself for doing it that's how I built
my self-esteem by getting up and doing
it by showing up
and it inspired the people who came out
they're saying well I you know I lived
25 minutes away didn't know if I wanted
to make the drive or commit to it I was
kind of tired and then I saw you with
your broken neck still showing up so I
had to show up too
right but that's not why I did it I did
it for me I did it for myself I had to
wear this all day all night long this
was my first one and then it started to
break so Nina put some duct tape on it
here and then this this was my second
one that once it started to really wind
down I couldn't wear it anymore I went
for this one and 10 minutes a day is all
I could do to take it off for a shower
so I had to sleep in this I had to do my
workshop in this everything
23 hours and 50 minutes a day except for
a 10 minute break in the shower where I
took it off and was paranoid about
moving anything because my neck was
broken I had to keep it stabilized I
wore these
this reminds me of how strong I am rule
number 44 alter your environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you exactly where you are the
people you hang with the videos you
watch the media you consume all of it
are perfectly designed to keep you
exactly where you are right now today if
you want to raise your standards it
starts by raising your environment first
so a friend of mine and friend of the
channel Mark Drager from Fanta gave me a
really warm message yesterday and he
thanked me for helping start the process
for him to turn from being a pessimist
to an optimist from being somebody who
was always worried and negative to
somebody who's having more energy who's
seen the light who's becoming more
optimistic who still has a road to go
but is so far further along than where
he was before and he wrote to me to say
thank you for starting me down this path
he said there was one conversation in
particular that had special meaning to
him where I told them that I I just
really believed in him that I saw a lot
of the people around him I saw a lot of
his peers and I just thought that he had
so much more potential than where he was
and I think maybe for the first time he
had an extra bolt of belief pushed into
him which is what I do which is what I'm
great at which what I enjoy doing fast
forward to now six months eight months
later he's made major gains in his life
he's he's brought on new team members he
is now consuming other content that is
positive and optimistic he's changing
his business around he's investing more
in himself he's happier he's lost a lot
of weight he's he's growing he's wanting
to strengthen his relationships he's
just seen a big shift in his life by
trying to move more into optimism
instead of pessimism and so it started
with my conversation with him he then
promoted somebody within his
organization to become CEO whose name
was Louis and he's also a massive Force
for good and positivity he started
consuming Gary's content which is
positivity he started consuming Tom
Billy's content which is positivity he
started now injecting all these these
people and resources into his life to
make him feel more positive more
optimistic more happy give him more
energy so that he has that to go take on
his goals and the challenges are in
front of him and slowly move that needle
from being a pessimist
to an optimist I don't think people are
pessimists to be honest I think
everybody is born an optimist I don't
think people are born
negative you know I think that's trained
into you I think you're pessimists and
negative because of the circumstances
you had and what was planted in your
brain by the people around you I think
people are good I think humans are just
good I think if we weren't good we
wouldn't be here anymore
99.99999 of people are good right some
people have a little bit of a miswiring
up there and it causes them to enjoy
killing people but for the most part
we're good I also believe that people
are built to serve
I believe that you get happiness from
helping others by being of service to
others that's what actually makes you
happy there aren't very many happy
moments in your life that didn't involve
somebody else you're helping you are
serving
they've shown the effect on your brain
of serving and helping somebody is the
same as food and sex we're literally
hardwired to help others and to serve
and so if you believe like I believe
that humans are good and humans are
built to serve then what would cause
somebody to be pessimistic and negative
how sad of an upbringing does that
person have to have had
the programming that was installed
inside them by other people who just
were negative and down on their life but
weren't inherently bad people the people
who stole from my car in La the guy who
cut me off in traffic yesterday I don't
think they're bad people I still think
they're good people who are built to
serve just circumstances and
conditioning have led them down a
negative path and so the good news is
you can get out of it just like my
friend Mark has who's someone who would
who was sworn to say I am a pessimist
right I just default to negativity
to now seeing the shift
by changing the people he's surrounded
himself with by altering his environment
by consuming content that is more
positive he has already seen a
noticeable shift with a past X number of
months and that's going to continue to
grow
that could be you too rule number 45
believe your biggest problem is a lack
of belief the only thing that's holding
you back holding me back holding your
friends and family back is a lack of
belief it is the world's biggest problem
and that's why I created these YouTube
channels I've seen the impact not just
on the people around me but myself
firsthand myself the value of having my
own channel in the work that I do I make
it selfishly for myself so that I learn
that I get better that I grow that I
challenge myself and it's often hard to
see it on a day-to-day basis you may not
feel a lot more confident have a lot
more belief from one day to the next you
might have some big win you might take
on some big Challenge and then you feel
good about yourself but then you fall
back down the next day and you don't see
that that's actually a win because the
wind that you had was so small the
growth that you had was so tiny that on
a day-to-day basis you can't see it
that's the problem but if you
consistently are doing the things like
watching this Channel or consuming a
podcast or reading the book or hanging
around people who are better than you
who have more belief than you who who
are growing and pushing that inspire you
if you're around that every single day
and you look back on your life you look
back in the past X number of months
you'll see how much you've grown you
just will I've seen it in my own
business go back and look at my old
content I started a new series on my
other channel where it's old oven versus
new Evan and the first video we did was
2016 Evan versus 2019 Evan and what do
you think and you may not see that big a
difference in me from last week's video
to this week's video or yesterday's
espresso to today's espresso but when
you go back three years see it doesn't
even look like the same person go back
10 years go back and watch my first
videos go back and watch their first
videos the content was still good the
message was still good but the delivery
the execution
sucked because I didn't know what I was
doing because I didn't have a lot of
belief and I'm still trying to chase the
next level you know I've grown and
believed but I'm never done the thing
that's holding me back it's still belief
it's belief and the ability to get to
the next step because as you expand your
comfort zone there's still other things
that are outside your comfort zone you
don't want to ever get to the point
where you're not growing where there's
not something outside your comfort zone
but then everything inside becomes easy
right what used to scare you now was
super easy and that wasn't a problem
anymore rule number 46 make sacrifices
there will be moments in your business
where you will need to have superhuman
strength to keep going where it just
demands everything from you every single
ounce that you have but if you need to
have superhuman energy every single day
you're gonna burn out and fail so
whenever I want to try something new
when I'm testing something new I always
eat into some of my reserves it may mean
to go off into this new project I'm
going to sleep less or spend a little
bit less time working on my book or a
little less time working on my YouTube
channel right you eat into these
Reserves but that's not sustainable if
that's what you're doing constantly
you're going to be unhappy you're going
to burn out you're going to fail so a
quick example uh sad Guru came to
Toronto sad Guru if you don't know he's
a yogi he's an Indian Mystic we did a
top 10 on him he then invited me to come
to his event in Toronto and then do a
one-on-one interview with him uh close
to the Toronto Airport the island was
amazing great time out of that he says
Evan I want you to come to my multi-day
event in the US I want you to come be a
VP guest there it'd be amazing to have
you awesome but before you do that you
have to do my seven day program where
you have to meditate every day for seven
days and I think it's an hour plus every
day I didn't have an hour a day right I
mean that's not part of what I had in my
calendar
every hour in my calendar is accounted
for it doesn't mean I'm working all that
time but I might be spending time with
my wife I'd be spending time with my son
and every every hour is accounted for
and so to do this I had to eat into some
of my reserves and so for that one I
asked me and I said Nina
if you're gonna come with me you have to
do this too do we want to spend our hour
in the evening instead of watching a
show instead of relaxing to to do this
program for seven days for meditation
and she said yes
and so here's the thing we did it for
seven days then we went to the event it
was awesome if it was something that we
were going to continue
if we're gonna meditate every day for an
hour ongoing then I'd have to readjust
my schedule your success comes from your
habits you need to figure what a
balanced life looks like for you now
ultimately I don't meditate an hour
every night I do some healing meditation
for my neck every morning but that habit
didn't stick and that's okay so when
you're testing new habits testing an
idea is testing something for your
business or some emergency comes up that
you have to deal with it's going to tap
into your reserves you can't be running
your business at full capacity already
you can't be running your business on
zero on empty because that means there's
no extra gear that means that when life
punches you in the face you can't handle
it that means if you want to try or
taste or test something else you can't
do it because you have no reserves you
have no battery there's no more gas in
the tank
and so that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs live that that's where
it's really Troublesome that's where a
lot of entrepreneurs will end up burning
out failing and crushing their dreams
because you're just running with no gas
left in the tank and so you can stretch
yourself I think that's normal I think
that's okay I think life will hit you in
the face and just when you think it
couldn't get worse here comes another
punch that will happen but it's making
sure that you can live that Balanced
Life whatever balance looks like for you
rule number 47 hold yourself accountable
you need people in your life to hold you
accountable because you will never push
yourself as hard as you can go you get a
personal trainer not because of what
exercises you should do you can look
that up online the real value of a
trainer is to have somebody right there
in front of you in your face telling you
to do three more reps of that exercise
when you want to quit when you're gonna
tap out and if you're by yourself you'd
say I'm done and they say give me three
more because all of the growth happens
in that last set if there's nobody
around you to hold you to a higher
standard you'll always know that there's
another level but you'll be too afraid
to reach for it yourself so let's use me
as an example
I want to solve the world's biggest
problem I don't think people believe in
themselves enough it's why I created
this Channel and all the other ones I
have and the books and the speaking
everything I do I want to go out and do
this impossible thing that's never going
to happen I'm never going to solve the
world's biggest problem and yet I wake
up every day and I try to do it and I
use a combination of what I call
aspirational mentors which are people
like Steve Jobs and Elon Musk and the
people that I profile on this channel
and then I also do it from people who
challenge me one-on-one if you watch my
entrepreneur advice Channel I get pushed
every week by my agent Steve by
psychologists in Australia by people who
are coaching me and I had to get better
and they push me and they tell me I need
to do more and they tell me I'm being an
idiot in these areas and like go this is
the homework
and the more uncomfortable I feel during
that process usually the better the
advice is if I think about the tour that
I launched last year another tour that
I'm doing this year
it started as a free tour and became a
paid tour when my agent Steve pushed me
to do it
like you need to charge for this and
immediately my heart's boom boom boom
boom boom I'm scared means I have to do
it
having people around you who can push
you to do the things that you need to do
who make you nervous who make you scared
who see your blind spots who cut through
your BS
who tell you that's just fear talking
because we'll come up with really
logical reasons why we can't do
something or aspirational mentors who
when you see how they react to things
how they see things how they understand
the world and then you look at what
you're doing it forces you to be pulled
up it forces you to take the next step
up on the staircase you need to do it
because your environment's been
perfectly designed to keep you where you
are your friends your family all of it
it's keeping you exactly where you are
and the difference between where you are
now and where you want to be and where
you can be in a year in two years in
five years in 10 years is going to be
the people you have around you and how
much they're willing to push you to
believe in you to tell you what you may
not want to hear but you need to hear to
grow to challenge yourself and get to
the next level rule number 48 own your
dreams when did you decide that your
dreams shouldn't be big when did you
decide that you shouldn't tell anyone
else about your dreams until you own
your dreams and stop making yourself
feel small those dreams will never
happen
never now this is something everybody
struggles with everybody myself Mel
everybody we're worried about playing a
bigger game we're worried about thinking
bigger for ourselves and we're worried
about telling other people because what
if it doesn't work out what if we don't
make it what's that judgment gonna come
how are they going to think about us and
so I think about my own story what I'm
trying to create the biggest fight that
I used to get into with my agent Steve
was he says Evan you need to be a
household name you need to be famous
like Steve I don't want to be famous
I I equated famous to Ego if you're
famous and you're just big eagle Maniac
I didn't I don't want to be an egomaniac
it's not it's not about me it's about
spreading belief I don't I'm nervous
getting in front of the camera even
before filming this video I'm nervous
like I wanted to wanted to do well the
lights come on I don't crave it I don't
crave attention I'm an introvert I like
just doing my thing Evan you need to get
famous why Steve why do I need to get
famous and for maybe two years we fought
over this
because I kept equating Fame with ego
and I looked at the people who were
famous and like I don't want to be like
them and there's a lot that they did
that that bothered me and I wanted to do
it a different way and that's the key
it's finding the different way to do it
how does an introvert on a mission
become famous I don't know we're gonna
go on this journey together and
hopefully find out what finally clicked
for me was him saying
when you get famous your mission will
spread
if you start tying actions to Mission
that's how you get me to move for other
people it might be hey I'll give you all
this money if you do this or you'll have
the fame or or credibility or have
statues but I don't need statues built
of me but as soon as you tie it to
Mission and service that gets me going
so he said if you actually want
to fulfill your mission if you say you
want to spread belief then you need to
get famous because the more people know
about you the more people will hear your
message and if finally it finally stuck
like okay I gotta do it I don't know how
to do it I've never I've never tried to
do it I've I've always wanted to be
behind the spotlight and so now now this
is part of my mission I need to become a
household name and get famous so that
more people can believe in themselves if
I actually want to solve the world's
biggest problem
then I need to be out there doing it I
need to believe in myself more
and if I'm trying to spread belief I
need to believe in myself more too
and so I think that's a human condition
that's part of what we want to do you
want to step outside your comfort zone
you want to serve humans are built to
serve we are we are built to serve but
service requires helping other people
and because we're afraid of judgment
you don't want to do it so you've got
your foot in the gas and a break at the
same time you want to help people but
you're worried about their judgment so
you don't do anything you know you're
capable of more you know you're capable
of more but you don't do it because
you're afraid rule number 49 kick
yourself forward bring yourself to other
people can be a fantastic thing a
fantastic thing but there's only one way
to make it work you have to kick
yourself forward not down you kick
yourself forward not down most people
here's what they do most people you see
someone who's that success you see
somebody with a Ferrari or the car or
somebody who you're jealous of or you're
insecure about yourself when you're
around them you see them and you you
think you suck you look at them and say
I suck why am I not further ahead why is
Dan who's not even 40 years old yet have
all of the success and here I am and I'm
not doing it yet
right you kick yourself down that's how
most people do it and in public you
might tell your friends how that
person's a scumbag you stole he's
ripping people off he's a jerk but when
you go home you just tell yourself man
why am I not for their head why am I why
am I here why am I stuck why am I not
getting more momentum you've been kicked
but you've been kicked down
where what you want to do is kick
yourself forward
you want to kick yourself forward if you
see Dan driving his Ferrari or you see
somebody that you look up to and respect
use it as a kick forward to say this is
what's possible this is what's possible
and if he can do it if she can do it
then I can do it too
my hero is Young Les Brown I love him
from a speaker just my favorite speaker
of all time I look at that and I say I
can get better
not that I suck it's that this is what's
possible I need to get better I need to
improve I need to practice I need to
keep going because that's what's
possible and rule number 50 the last one
before very special bonus clip is never
give up Paul Newman the legendary actor
had an amazing quote that I love to
repeat he said I check my pulse and if I
can find it I know I've got a chance
you've got a very important choice to
make you either make the rest of your
life the best of your life or you settle
for what is and live in your excuses so
you know why I would give up you know
what I'm deeply afraid of I've got two
I've got a short-term fear and a
long-term fear my short-term fear is of
disappointing people my biggest short
term in the moment fear is disappointing
people that I would show up to an event
and let people down that I wouldn't give
them value that people would come and
waste their time spend their money and I
didn't give them value I'm deeply afraid
of it and still I'm I put pressure on
these videos I want these videos to be
great every time I get in front of this
camera and start making a video I put
pressure myself that this seems to be
the best video that I've ever done I
want to not disappoint you guys every
single time and this little pause
hesitation before filming and I'll spend
a couple minutes procrastinating because
I'm I'm afraid I'm afraid of
disappointing you and making a crappy
video I'll procrastinate and then I'll
do it and I'll feel great at doing it
but my biggest short-term fear
disappointing people my biggest
long-term fear is of regret is that I
won't live my life is that I'll look
back and say I could have done more I I
should have pushed harder because you
rarely regret the things that you did
it's the things that you didn't do the
things you were too afraid to do the
action's not taken that's what you
normally regret
and so my biggest short-term fear is
disappointing people maybe because the
long-term fear is fear of regret and
those things
they fight each other
right they fight each other because if
I'm afraid of disappointing somebody I'm
not going to take the action that I
should be taking and then I'm going to
regret it later on and so I try to use
that to your potential regret to push me
into action to say if I don't make
videos today if I don't do that speech
if I don't get up and make that
presentation if I don't do the thing
that I'm afraid to do
because of disappointing people
potentially then I'll regret it
and I'll put the pressure like this is
the video this video right here this is
a video that's gonna blow up everything
that'll change the whole game for me and
if I don't record it because I'm afraid
of disappointing somebody I'm gonna
regret that my whole life and I make it
so painful for myself that then I have
to act and that pain pushes me into
action and out of procrastination mode
not have a very special bonus coat from
Evan learn how to enjoy the process but
before that it's time for the three
important Landing questions let's go
from watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to kick yourself forward number
two where do you need to stop hiding and
number three what is the rejection that
you need to stop fearing living a joyful
life comes from enjoying the process of
what you are doing when you wake up
every morning do you look forward to the
work that you're about to do today or do
you hate it do you dread it and want to
stay in bed if you are waking up and
going to do work that is torture to you
that you don't enjoy that you dread on a
daily basis you will never be joyful or
successful and I want to change that so
is on a call yesterday with a buddy of
mine who had built a Million Dollar Plus
business and he said Evan I don't know
what to do I'm I'm unhappy I'm depressed
I don't like my business I've built this
business that I hate going to and I'm
and I've always hated most of what I've
done I've had success I've built a
Million Dollar Plus business but I've
always hated the work and I thought you
have to hate the work to get the results
that you want
but I keep hearing you and all these
other successful people saying you gotta
love the process you gotta love the work
so what do I do man I don't know what to
do do I do I shut the whole thing down
do I keep building what do I do I'm lost
I said hey man there's something that
you love inside your business what do
you love doing and it started off was
well I like giving people strategy I
like doing the strategy part of my
business but I don't like the rest of it
okay great so Step One is you're gonna
start doing all the strategy work in
your business amazing what else like
while I also like selling okay awesome
you're gonna be the chief salesperson
you're going to be off selling and
meeting people and having conversations
it's like I don't like delivering I
don't like the operations awesome that's
why you've hired your CEO to run your
company
and then he said I also like having
conversations and mentoring people not
everybody on my team likes to be
mentored but I love mentoring people I
love guiding them so he's got three
things that he loves doing he looks
forward to that he wishes he could do
all day and luckily those are high value
skills for his business right he wants
to be able to set the strategy and help
his clients with strategy he wants to be
able to sell and he wants to be able to
mentor and guide the people on his team
he just doesn't want to deliver
so you either become a consultant where
this is all you do or you hire somebody
who he's already bought on who's your
CEO and give him more lateral give him
more abilities give him more power give
him more permission and at the same time
if he loves mentoring and training
people he loves people who will listen
to him and be open to his guidance and
wisdom then he needs to have a team who
respects him who wants that and not
everybody will you could have the
greatest person who can write copy or
the greatest programmer or the greatest
whatever for your business but if you
love mentoring and they don't want to be
mentored that's not a good fit
so you need to do an assessment on your
team and see who loves being mentored by
you and keep those people because
if you go into work every day and you
see the people who you love being with
who you love mentoring who you feel like
you're a team with you'll love going to
work but if you go to work every day and
you see these people who don't want to
listen to you who don't want to be
trained you don't want to be Mentor just
want to sit down and do their work
it's not going to be a joyful experience
for you
and that lack of Joy will mean you won't
have success in your company as well and
so he's built up this machine that he
hates because he always thought you need
to hate the work like work is work it
sucks but you get the results like no
dude it's the exact opposite you've had
success you built a Million Dollar Plus
business because you're talented but it
should have been a 10 million dollar
plus business by now and if you want
more Evan check out his top 50 rules
video the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and we'll see you
there